Cosa sono le utopie
cosa sono per te per te per te
e per te
sono dei
sogni irrealizzabili
impossibili
qualcosa di astruso
ecco
andiamo con ordine nel 2007
arrivo a Riesi perché mi chiamano per
diventare il direttore del Servizio
Cristiano di Riesi e lì in mezzo agli
ulivi incontro la storia di Tullio
capello strano un po' come il mio
sguardo penetrante mai Severo e Leonardo
che sembra un Divo del cinema slanciato
atletico
e della loro amicizia entrambi sono
mossi da due utopie l'utopia del mondo
nuovo per Tullio che vuol diventare
teologo protestante l'utopia della
comunità Per Leonardo che vuole invece
diventare architetto entrambi nascono
all'inizio del Novecento a Roma e si
incontrano a Firenze due vite parallele
che non si sarebbero mai incontrate se
l'utopia non ci avesse messo lo zampino
Durante gli anni del secondo conflitto
mondiale
nel periodo del rastrellamento degli
ebrei da Firenze Tullio decide che
bisogna fare qualcosa
e insieme all'amico Leonardo decidono di
dedicare una parte dell'appartamento
della famiglia di Tullio a nascondere le
famiglie degli ebrei
per questo molti anni dopo Tullio verrà
riconosciuto Giusto tra le nazioni dallo
Stato di Israele
Mmm ma qualcosa inquieta entrambi
sentono che devono fare di più E così
insieme progettano il centro di Agape
sarà esattamente questa parola Agape
amore smisurato profondo sconfinato a
metterli insieme Per il resto della loro
vita
nelle valli piemontesi di Prali
progettano il centro ecumenico di Agape
perché le mani che un tempo si erano
combattute di tedeschi italiani inglesi
francesi che avevano imbracciato le armi
gli uni contro gli altri potessero
invece ritrovarsi per costruire un luogo
di confronto di riconciliazione di pace
ma qualcosa ancora non va
Tullio sente
che l'inquietudine lo chiama che bisogna
passare dalle prediche alle pratiche che
bisogna
rendere concreto questo Agape e così
insieme all'amico Leonardo si incontrano
a Roma e si scambiano pacchetti di
sigarette Avvolti da una nuvola di fumo
enorme entrambi incalliti fumatori
progettano il Servizio Cristiano di
Riesi
senza un soldo
e lo realizzano
perché Riesi perché Riesi al centro
della Sicilia era il territorio dove
violenza contro le donne povertà
schiavitù della terra da parte dei
contadini e i Carusi delle miniere di
zolfo facevano sentire più forti i morsi
della violenza
bisognava creare delle scuole
luoghi di incontro lavoro sviluppo
giustizia
in quel territorio loro realizzano la
struttura che voi Vedete ora Voi
potreste dirmi ok Gianluca tutto bello
tutto poetico anche interessante forse
non so ma ma tu che c'entri in tutto
questo Beh lo diceva all'inizio nel 2007
mi viene rivolto l'invito a diventare
direttore di questa struttura e quando
arrivo in quel luogo l'utopia devo dire
molto sinceramente si era da tempo
esaurita
le strutture realizzate da Leonardo
fatiscenti carenti
i collaboratori un po' demotivati forse
anche tanto
persino gli ulivi tra i quali camminavo
sembravano piangere sembravano tristi e
se ci passava in mezzo sembrava quasi di
sentirsi piangere allora
potevamo scegliere due strade
farci imprigionare dalla paura e
arrivare alla consunzione oppure
decidere di scardinare quella zona di
comfort che è esattamente la paura che
mentre da un lato ci preoccupa
dall'altro ci tranquillizza e ci
imprigiona perciò ci tiene Fermi e
rimetterci in movimento e abbiamo
trovato in una piccola parola la
soluzione al problema e la parola era
insieme
non importa quanto tempo possa servire
ma è insieme agli altri che le utopie ti
incontrano e ti mettono in movimento
così insieme ai miei collaboratori del
tempo abbiamo rimesso mano le scuole
riavviato la didattica provato a fare
una didattica più inclusiva e un po'
avveniristica come qualcuno ci ha fatto
notare in quel momento abbiamo
realizzato Le aule tematiche una sorta
di college all'americana per i bambini
della scuola primaria però
insomma
il territorio Si è messo in movimento
noi con questo territorio il territorio
con noi
nella condivisione delle azioni ma
sentivo che ancora qualcosa non
funzionava
che mancava un pezzettino di strada da
fare
l'inquietudine mi colse
ed allora un'intuizione ecco Se doveste
chiedermi oggi Gianluca cos'è per te
l'utopia Io direi che l'utopia è il
luogo non ancora raggiunto più
l'intuizione
E allora nel 2017 insieme ad un geniale
amico architetto abbiamo immaginato il
laboratorio umano di rigenerazione
territoriale il Lourdes Dove sensibilità
diverse culture diverse professionalità
diverse potessero insieme
contaminarsi per rigenerare le persone e
quindi anche il territorio
ed era esattamente quest'altra parolina
contaminazione che ci ha proiettato
oltre l'ostacolo oltre gli ostacoli
avevamo ricevuto
in gestione un bene confiscato a cosa
nostra e avevamo deciso che lì avremmo
realizzato la sede del laboratorio umano
di rigenerazione territoriale avevamo
iniziato ad immaginare la contaminazione
eravamo carichi molto carichi per questo
progetto ed è arrivata la pandemia e
quindi la parola contaminazione
è diventata un leggerissimo problema
ogni qualvolta ne parlavamo qualcuno
correva a disinfettarsi le mani in
realtà non ci siamo persi d'animo perché
mentre tutto ciò che stava attorno a noi
chiudeva le menti rimanevano aperte ed
allora abbiamo pensato a cosa fare a
chiamare raccolta giovani da ogni parte
d'Europa d'Italia e del territorio per
costruire la casa blu
e riappropriarci di uno spazio del
territorio ma anche in questo caso
l'utopia non la puoi chiudere dentro
delle scatole e infatti tutti i nostri
progetti sono andati
in fumo in 5 minuti perché decine di
bambini si sono incaricati di
dirci che non era quella l'esigenza del
territorio che serviva altro serviva un
luogo dove farli giocare farli studiare
farli incontrare
riappropiandoci anche della strada
Ecco
noi avevamo raggiunto un orizzonte
Ma quando ci siamo arrivati davanti a
noi se ne sono aperti tanti altri in
fondo come scriveva Edoardo Galeano
cos'è l'utopia mi muovo di due passi si
sposta di due passi mi muovo di 10 passi
si sposta i 10 passi Vuoi vedere che
l'utopia è un modo per camminare per
andare avanti probabilmente così adesso
oggi se dovessi dirla in maniera
sintetica la direi così l'utopia è un
camminare in una piazza immensa
affollata che è il mondo a braccia
aperte
Grazie
[Applauso]